this is a really cool course that
teaches you how to use javascript and
html to create a puzzle game that uses
the video feed from a camera you will
also learn a bit of html and sql
radio has a unique and interesting style
that makes learning the concepts really
fun
hi i'm radu and today i'm going to teach
you how to make a puzzle game that uses
the camera
this whole project is done using only
vanilla javascript and html canvas and a
small part of it
this one here is done using php and
mysql to save and load scores from the
database
the game works on desktop computers but
also on mobile devices like phones and
tablets
by watching this you'll learn many
useful things that you can later apply
in other projects
even though some of these things are
quite advanced i'll teach them as simple
as i can and i'll leave the two most
complicated things at the end good news
is that they're also optional meaning
that you can get a fully working game
without them
so don't be scared it'll be fun i
promise
also special thanks to bo from free code
camp for allowing me to share this with
you guys i hope you'll like it and if
you have any questions do contact me via
my youtube channel
now let's begin
we begin by writing the html page
in the header we give the page a title
this will change what we see here in the
browser tab
and we'll also link the two external
files
one for the javascript and another for
the css
these files are just empty for now
then the body part of our document will
be really simple for now we just run a
function called main when the page loads
and add the canvas element here which is
what we'll primarily use to build the
game it will be a canvas app
if we refresh the page now we see the
tab shows the correct title
and we also get an error here in the
console
if you don't see the console in your
browser try pressing f12 it's the
shortcut for the developer tools in most
browsers
i'm using google chrome i think it has
the most useful tools but it's really
just a personal preference any one of
them will work just fine
now the error says that this main
function is missing so let's move to our
javascript file and implement it
for now i'll just make it output the
string main into the console to test if
it works
and it does
it's very good to debug like this
whenever you make a change otherwise
errors pile up and it can be very
confusing to deal with many of them at
once
but now let's see how to access the
camera
we'll use a promise to get access to our
media devices
we're only interested in the video
coming from the camera and we specify
that here
what happens now is that the browser
will ask the player for permission to
use the camera
when they give it the code will go here
where we define a callback function in
which we have access to the camera
signal
if the player doesn't allow the camera
or there is some other error we will
catch it and show it on screen
when everything works out we initialize
a video object
we'll use a global variable for this and
i will write these in capital letters to
make it clear when a variable is global
or not in the code
we next create the video element
initialize it to the signal coming from
the camera
and play it
when video data is available we can
start updating it on the canvas
this update canvas function is what we
will implement next but first let's also
define the canvas here globally and add
a reference to the canvas context object
as well
we initialize the canvas with the one
defined in the html page previously
this 2d context of the canvas provides
all drawing methods we will need to
build the game our canvas will fill the
entire window
now the update canvas function needs to
draw the video onto the canvas so we
will use the draw image method of the
canvas context to do just that
we also need to specify here that we
want to start drawing from the top left
corner which has zero zero coordinates
now when i refresh something happens it
shows the image coming from my camera
my camera is just pointed at the wall
here at the moment
but it doesn't pick up any movement just
yet we need to update the canvas many
times per second to see this happen and
we'll use the request animation frame
method to make it work
this method will call the function
recursively many times per second and it
will try to update 60 times per second
if the computer is fast enough
now we get a live image
let me just put mr chibison here to make
it less boring
now you'll notice a white border here
it's a bit strange because we said we
want to draw the video at zero zero
but the body element has some default
margin and that's what we are actually
seeing
we'll remove that by going to our css
file and changing the style of the body
element by setting the margin to zero
better now but we still get these scroll
bars here which are not really necessary
so i'll remove them by setting overflow
to hidden
now the scroll bars are gone but the
video actually goes outside the screen
we don't want that
and we need to keep in mind that in
general there are many webcams or phone
cameras out there with different
resolutions aspect ratios and so on
so we need a way to resize the video so
that it fits in the middle of the screen
preferably with some space around it so
that we have enough room to move the
pieces later
we'll use this scaler to specify how
much of the screen space will be used by
the image
and i will also keep track of other
related information in this size
variable
we update these values here when
metadata about the video is available
first we use a helper variable to find
out the minimum ratio between the screen
size and the video size
and then we set the size attributes
accordingly
note that here one of these things will
simplify so we properly preserve the
aspect ratio and nothing gets stretched
for the x and y coordinates we start off
in the middle of the screen
and go just half the width towards the
left and half the height towards the top
then to actually affect the image we
must update the draw image method here
this method can be called with a
different number of arguments
before we just specified the top left
corner but now we also add the width and
the height
okay it works we now see the entire
image coming from the camera before it
was slightly cropped on the right
we also get this 80 margin
and if we change the value here we get a
different sized margin instead
we can also check to see how the
application looks on different sized
screens by pressing this button
we can even select some specific device
from this list
but every time we change something we
need to refresh the page to see it
happen
looks good
how about in landscape mode
need to refresh again
we could actually make this resizing
happen automatically by using an event
listener for the window resize
we then need to move this code in the
callback function
and also need to call this function here
so that the code executes as before
and i should also move these lines here
too
in this way the canvas will resize as
well not just the camera stream
ok let's see
if we change the orientation
yes it works
no matter what the screen size we will
get the proper fitting this time
but even more important is that it will
work regardless of the size and aspect
ratio your camera outputs
i'll demonstrate this by forcing my
webcam to output a specific size
note that not all webcams support
resizing in this way and it may not work
for you but you can try
you can see it works just fine with the
square aspect ratio
let's try a vertical aspect ratio next
ok works just fine
i will remove these extra parameters now
because we want to see the entire video
coming from the camera
this was just an experiment
and i will actually comment out this
event listener because we don't really
need this functionality inside the app
users are not expected to resize the
screen like this
i made it to demonstrate better how
things work and avoid refreshing all the
time
plus you may need it in one of your
projects
we now define the piece class and
specify a row and column index in the
constructor
we will have an array of these pieces
and define it globally here
we also need to specify how many rows
and columns there are
and i will store these here
now to initialize the pieces we begin
with an empty array
and iterate through the rows using the i
variable and through the columns using
the j variable and add a new piece
defined using these two indices into the
array
to be able to draw the pieces we are
going to implement the draw method that
takes the context as a parameter
let's first just draw a simple rectangle
here to see if what we did so far is
working
now we need to figure out the location
and the size of these pieces based on
the number of rows columns and the size
of the video on the screen
i will enter these placeholders here and
calculate the exact values in the
constructor
the width and height of each piece is
just the width and height of the area
divided by the number of columns and
rows respectively
i set here the x and y to be so that
each piece is defined to be at the
correct location at first
even though this is a puzzle game where
the player needs to find out what the
correct locations are it helps to start
with the solved configuration when
developing the game
you'll see
i realize now that x and y could
actually be defined after we have the
width and the height
and then define them using the width and
height like this
the code is clearer in this way
we now need a way to draw the pieces
we do this here by just iterating
through all of them and calling the draw
method using the global context
okay i think we're ready to debug now oh
i forgot to call the stroke method here
without it nothing will be drawn
let's see i'll refresh and
nothing is different just yet
it's because the pieces array is empty
we need to call the initialize pieces
function and we'll do this in the
console for now
okay now something happens and it looks
good three rows and three columns
but it's not ready yet
these are just empty rectangles drawn on
top of the video
look if i comment out drawing the video
image here
you can just see the grid
each piece needs to crop a specific part
of the video and show it
we do that by adding a call to the draw
image method here
we use another version of the draw image
method
a more complicated one that accepts nine
arguments
after we specify the video we need to
tell the left part where the cropping
happens
then the top part
then the width and the height
these values are relative to the video
and whatever the resolution and aspect
ratio it has
now after we specify where to take the
image data from
we need to say where to draw it
this is easy it's just at the piece x
and y location and we need to use its
width and height
okay it now looks the same as before but
each piece is showing the part of the
video it's responsible for
we can actually parameterize this
function here to support any number of
rows and columns
and we just call it here with default
values in the beginning
we can test in the console by using
different sized grids
let's randomize the location of the
pieces next
we'll just write a function where we
iterate through all of them and generate
a random location for each piece
we set here the x and y respectively
we call this in the console and
it's not what we expect
the random values are between 0 and 1
meaning that they are all pretty much in
the top left corner here
i'm not gonna go into how half pixels
work
so let's just move on and scale these by
the canvas width and height
ok much better but you can see that some
pieces go outside the screen here
we can prevent that by subtracting the
piece width and height here when scaling
okay good
now the reason why we see duplicate
pieces
once randomly distributed and others
that are behind and in the correct
locations
is that we are not clearing the canvas
before redrawing each frame
if we do this here
and randomize the pieces again
we get what we expect
let's test different grid sizes as well
neat
i actually want to have an idea of where
the pieces need to go it will make
debugging easier and maybe we can keep
it as a
easy mode or something like that
so
i'll move this clear wrecked call to the
top
set the 50 transparency
and uncomment drawing the video we had
earlier
then i reset the transparency so that
only the video is semi-transparent but
the pieces are drawn normally after that
in this way the video on the background
shows where i need to move the pieces
but it's faded so it won't be confused
with the actual pieces
now to implement the drag and drop
functionality for the pieces we need to
add some event listeners to the canvas
we implement a function for it here and
begin by adding an event listener for
mousedown with a callback function that
we will need to define
then two more event listeners for mouse
move and mouse up will also be needed
to handle the mouse down event we first
mark down what is the selected piece by
getting the one the user presses in the
interface
we will define this function soon but
let's get the top level logic down first
we'll store the selected piece inside
the global variable which we initialize
with null in the beginning or if no
piece is pressed
then if a piece is selected we calculate
what is the offset to the top left
corner of the piece like this
we will use this offset while dragging
so that the piece doesn't just snap to
the mouse location like this
it will make for a smoother interaction
then on mouse move if a piece is
selected we update the location to the
new mouse location and consider the
offset as well
the mouse up event will just leave empty
for now
so how do we find out if the player
presses a piece or not
well all we need to do is iterate
through all the pieces and check to see
if the click location is within the
bounds of any of them
we need to check if x is greater than
the piece is x
and less than that plus the piece's
width
and if the y is greater than the pieces
y
and less than that plus the piece's
height
if so we just return this piece
if nothing matches these conditions we
just return null which means that
nothing was pressed
okay let's test i move the mouse over
the bottom left corner piece i click
and drag
great but now i'm stuck like this
i need to implement the mouse up event
so that i can actually let go of the
piece
now the obvious thing that we need to do
is set the selected piece to null
but before that we need to do one more
thing
we check if the piece is close
to the correct location where it's
supposed to go
and if so we snap it in place
we will need to implement these new
methods but first let's discuss why
we're doing this
the first reason is that it gives proper
feedback
when a player lets go of the piece if it
jumps into place it means that the move
was correct
and the player can move on to the next
one the second reason is that later we
will need to evaluate if the pieces are
in the correct position or not
and it's very unlikely that the player
will be able to drop all pieces in a
pixel perfect way so this snapping will
help with that as well
final reason is that i think it makes
the game more interesting and fun to
play
so to implement this functionality we go
back to the piece class and add the two
new methods
first we check if the piece is close to
the correct location
we do that by simply calculating the
distance to the correct location and
checking if it's under a threshold
i use a threshold that is proportional
to the size of the piece here
about 33
i just did some trial and error and i
think it feels good like that
if the distance is less
then it's considered close
otherwise it's not
the correct locations should be stored
somewhere and i'll do that here in the
constructor because we already agreed
that the pieces will be initialized at
the correct location
to measure the distance we just use a
consequence of the pythagorean theorem
i'm pretty sure you know it already but
if you don't or want to learn something
more about it
check out the recent video i made about
it
i think i did a pretty good job
explaining it proving it and giving all
kinds of applications what do you guys
think
the snap method is really easy
it just puts the piece in the correct
location and that's it
let's debug
now i can go and click on a piece
drag it and release
i can release it anywhere i want and if
i drop it close to the correct location
it will snap into place
and this works for every piece but one
issue is that the selected piece is
sometimes drawn underneath the others
this is not good
it depends on the order we are drawing
the pieces
since the top left one is the first in
the array all others will be drawn on
top of it
but the bottom right one doesn't have
this problem it's always on top
we need to fix this by moving the
selected piece at the last index in the
array
we first find out the index it's
currently at
then even though it should not be
possible for it to be missing i check
here just to be sure
i then remove it using the splice method
and add it again at the end of the array
using the push method
now no matter which piece i select it
will be drawn on top of everything as
expected
but there's still one problem
when i click here where multiple pieces
overlap it selects the bottom most piece
we fix this by iterating the pieces
array in reverse order
in this way
we stop at the topmost piece that the
user is clicking on
now everything works well but one final
thing we need to consider is mobile
devices
what we did so far actually doesn't work
on those yet
see even if i debug using this mode and
i try dragging pieces around nothing
happens
this is because mobile uses touch events
instead of mouse events
so we need to support those as well
go back to the function where we add
event listeners
copy all three of them and rewrite what
is necessary
the touch start touch move and touch end
callback functions will need to be
defined next
but they are easy to do because we will
reuse the mouse event callback functions
from earlier
we just need to get the location here in
a little different way
and then we can call the other callback
like this
we copy this callback function and
implement the other two
now when we debug it works
but an error happens on touch end
that's because there's no location
available then
i mean if you're not touching
where are you not touching
so we actually omit these arguments here
now everything works when i'm debugging
here but some mobile devices have a
built-in function that refreshes the
page when dragging down
we don't want this to happen every time
a player drags a piece downwards
so we disable it in the css file by
setting over scroll behavior to none
that's it for the drag and drop
let's just see if it also works with
different sized pieces
next we add gameplay elements like the
menu and showing the elapsed time
we need to define some more structure in
the html page
a div that will contain all these new
elements
a div for the menu and the div for
showing the time
the menu will contain a select component
for setting the difficulty
there will be four different options and
when the user changes these we will call
a function called set difficulty which
we'll need to define in javascript
we also need the button here to start
the game pressing it will call a
function called restart that we'll also
need to define in javascript
so let's move to the javascript file
next
we add two new global variables to keep
track of the start and end time
we then implement the set difficulty
function
first we get the value of the select
component we defined in html
based on that we call the initialize
pieces function with a different number
of rows and columns
i'm using a switch case structure here
to avoid many if else statements
it's a common mistake my students make
the values i use here are just guesses
pretty much
but for the insane variant i wanted to
have exactly 1000 pieces so i use 40 and
25 which has the most square aspect
ratio
then the restart function will set the
start time variable to the current
timestamp
and the end time is set to null because
we just started playing
we also randomized the pieces at this
stage
if i refresh we don't see the menu
anywhere
actually it flashes rapidly before the
page loads but where does it go
we can use the developer tools to
inspect the elements and see that they
are pushed below the bottom of the page
by the canvas
we can actually try out different styles
here to get it to work
setting an absolute positioning with the
zero top will do the trick for now
so i will add this to our css file
refreshing now it works
i can press start and it will randomize
the pieces each time
and if i change the difficulty level we
see the different sized grids coming up
i thought the insane mode would be too
processor intensive at first
but it works fine on my computer at
least
i'm sure some devices will struggle
though
next we display the time i will define a
function called updatetime that first
takes the current time from the system
then it takes the div we defined earlier
to hold this value and sets the inner
html to the difference between now and
the start time
we need to call this function somewhere
so i will go to the update canvas
function that is called on every frame
and enter it here
we also notice that this name is not
proper anymore because now we update
more than just the canvas here
so i will refactor it a bit
when i refresh now i press start and it
shows the time here
but it's in milliseconds and we should
format it properly
i'll first convert it to seconds by
keeping the integer part of the
milliseconds when dividing by 1000
then i want to consider this format
so we need to know the seconds part
between 0 and 59
and we will get it like this
the minute part also between 0 and 59
can be obtained like this
and the hour part is between 0 and 23
and we get it like this i doubt anybody
will spend more than a day playing this
then to format them into the final
string i take each component and do a
left padding with 0 if necessary
i use a column between each part
then we return this final value and
that's it
now we can use it here to format the
difference
starts to feel like a real game already
don't you think
but nothing happens when we're done we
need to detect somehow that all pieces
are in the correct locations
we do that by adding an attribute here
that will say if the location is correct
or not
initially it should be because the
pieces are defined at the correct
location
but then when we randomize we
immediately set it to false
then when a piece is snapped to the
correct location we set it to true again
it's possible that someone grabs a piece
from the correct location
so we need to set it back to false here
on mouse down
then to check if all the pieces are
correct we write a function like this
it goes through all pieces
and if even one of them is not correct
the function returns false
otherwise we return true
we check this in the mouse up callback
function because the game can only be
completed when the player releases a
piece
the last piece that goes in the correct
location
here we also need to check if the end
time is null because in principle the
player can continue to move pieces
around after the game is over and we
don't want to update the time anymore
after that
we just set the end time here to the
current time
we also need to change the display here
so that if an end time is available the
difference to that is shown and not the
difference to the current time
okay let's see now
timer starts counting same as before
we play the game
and now the timer
stopped now we'll make this part look
better
first let's put the button below like
this
now we can move to the css file and
position these in the center of the
screen
we say that the items should be 50
percent from the left and 50 from the
top
now if we leave it like this the items
will move here so their top left corner
is in the center screen
but we would like them to be here so we
need to add transform translate minus
fifty percent minus fifty percent
and now we get this
now the text isn't clearly readable as
such
let's add the semi-transparent
background here like this
better now we can align the items to
center like this
we can give the items some spacing
around by setting a value for the
padding
i'm using a value of 5 min here which
means that the spacing will be five
percent of the minimum between the width
and height of the window
i also set the black semi-transparent
border here as
well now we can make the button look
better
we'll give it a larger font size
and a bluish background color
and white text
good
we can make the button more
user-friendly by changing its properties
when mouse is hovering it
i'll make it have an orange background
and black text in this case
okay now when i hover it changes style
you can't see my mouse here now for some
reason but it's there and it looks like
the default arrow
to make it look like a hand cursor we
can change it here in css
nowadays there are many fancy features
you can choose when styling elements
like you can easily add animations with
the transition property
by setting this 0.3 second duration here
we will get a short animation from one
style to the other on hover i think it's
really nice
i don't like this border here so i'll
remove it and i will make the bottom
corners round by setting a small radius
the font size apart from this button is
rather small
so we'll work on that next
first i change it to arial
i think that the serifs don't look very
good in this case
okay now i'll make it bigger same as the
font size on the button
i think it's okay now
let's see how it would look like on
mobiles as well
it's definitely readable
i think it could be a bit bigger but
this will also do for now the text on
the select component is not affected yet
so we need to specifically add the font
size there as well
okay switching back to full screen now
i'll change the mouse to look like a
pointer when hovering this select
component as well and style this element
to be more in line with the button
so no border a small radius and we need
to remove the outline here as well
okay let's try testing the game now
i press start and
it's not what we want really
this menu should disappear at this stage
and only the timer should remain visible
so i will go back to the html and take
out this element from here
then in the javascript file we go to the
restart function and set the display of
the menu items to none
now i refresh press the start button and
the menu is gone but the timer is gone
as well
it should be there let's debug
i switch to the elements panel and
it is there it is just below the canvas
so we need to change its style in css
i want it on the top of the screen so i
will change positioning to absolute
set the zero top
and let's have it center screen
so i set left to 50
and i use the transform translate method
again but only on the left side now i
refresh press start and the timer is
there
next i'll show you how to draw a logo
using powerpoint
you can use a number of different
software to do this i'm using powerpoint
just because it's installed on most
student computers so hopefully you have
it too
i use the rounded rectangle tool to
start drawing a camera i can adjust the
corner radius like this
now i make a copy of the item by holding
down the ctrl key and dragging it to a
new location
i will do a similar thing with circles
now
i will change the colors to just black
and white for the circles
and i will use the align tools to make
sure they are just the way i want them
to be i change the color of the
rectangles drawn earlier to black and
move the circles on top
newer features of powerpoint have these
helper lines appearing and they are
useful i think but if you don't have
them and want to have proper alignment
just use the align tools we used earlier
now i'm happy with how this looks so i
will copy it and paste it as an image we
will need to use it later in this format
but now i want to draw a small puzzle
piece
so i start off with a rectangle about
this size
and i draw an oval here as well
i will shape this oval to look more like
the connecting part of puzzle pieces and
i do that by editing the points of this
shape
right click edit points
it's useful if you understand how bezier
curves work at this stage
ok i'm happy with this
i copy it
rotate it on its side
and merge these three items into a
single shape by going to merge shapes
and union
now i'll place this on top of the image
copy of our camera align it a bit better
and duplicate both objects on the right
for the first copy we select first the
camera image
then holding shift
press on the puzzle piece as well
go to merge shapes and subtract
for the second copy also select the
camera image first
then holding shift press on the puzzle
piece as well
go to merge shapes and intersect
i now move this piece into place so that
it looks like we're just completing the
puzzle
now select these two objects copy and
paste as image
at this point we don't need all the
other items anymore
we just keep this one as the icon and
we'll use it to make a title next
i just create a text box and write
puzzle cam here in all caps
i set the font to arial black to be
similar to that in the html page
and increase the size of the font
i then make the p larger
and i want it to be the same size as the
camera
so a bit of trial and error goes here
and when we're happy with it apply the
same size to letter c and we're almost
done
we can now copy everything and paste as
an image once again
but you'll see that the image has some
weird transparent margins here
it's how powerpoint works when text
boxes are involved unfortunately
but we can crop that out using the
cropping tool
resize the image to the size we want
right click and save as picture
then i name it as title.png
and add it to the same directory as our
code
speaking of which we can now add the new
image to the html file like this
and i'll set its width to 90 percent
inline here because there's no other
style i will add to this
then refreshing makes the image appear
i think it will look better if we do one
small change in css
i will make the whole menu wider like
this in this way the title image is
significantly larger than the other text
and the drop down for the difficulty
moved on the same line as the label i
think it's better like this
let's add some sounds next
first i'll define one using an mp3 file
i recorded earlier like this
i'll set the volume quite low because
this will play whenever we drop a piece
in the correct place
it would be really annoying if it plays
at maximum volume i think
so let's now add it here in the snap
method and test
i refresh the page press start and
yay
it works
but there is no sound when completing
the game and there definitely needs to
be something there
instead of simply adding another mp3
file here which would make this tutorial
really short
i will remind you that it's possible to
synthesize sounds in javascript to
generate the sounds we will need to
define an audio context and doing it
like this will make it work on most
browsers
then i want to create a simple melody
consisting of three notes played on
piano keys here i'm writing their
frequencies
we need to create a function to play a
single note
it will have a specified key and a given
duration how long the key should be
pressed
we next define an oscillator
this will be responsible for generating
the sound with a given frequency
we set the frequency to the value coming
as a parameter here
we start the oscillator like this at the
current time
and we can also tell it to stop after
the specified duration
it is good to also disconnect the
oscillator at the same time otherwise
some hardly noticeable background noise
can still be heard on some browsers
i'm using set timeout for that and i
specify the duration here as well
now there's a problem because set
timeout expects the duration in
milliseconds
but the stop method expects it in
seconds
so i decided it to be in milliseconds
and need to divide here by 1000
one more thing we need to do before we
test is to connect the oscillator to the
destination which in this case is the
default speakers on your device
okay let's test
i do that by calling the play note here
in the console
and we get an error
looks like i don't know how to spell
oscillator
let me just fix that real quick and
you can hear a simple sound for one
second
now we begin to shape this to sound more
like a piano
i will use an envelope to control the
gain
you can think of it as the volume in a
sense i connect the envelope now to the
destination and i change the oscillator
here to be connected to this envelope
instead forming a kind of chain
then the piano sound has a powerful
attack which means that it needs to go
from zero to maximum gain really quickly
here it happens in 0.1 of a second
i set the maximum here to be 0.5 instead
of 1 so that it's not too loud
then the gain will gradually decrease
back to 0 for the given duration
again specified here in seconds
now let's refresh and test
another error
i sure do many of those today it seems
the problem is that i connect the
oscillator here to the envelope before i
even define it
so moving it down here should work
you can now hear the sound gradually
fading during the course of one second
[Music]
and you can get an even nicer sound by
changing the wave type from the default
sign to triangle
[Music]
if you're having trouble understanding
these things do check out my visual web
development course
there i use a much slower pace and
explain all the different techniques i
needed to make my augmented reality
piano
now let's compose the melody itself
it will start with a simple note at
first played for 300 milliseconds
then i'll play a different note after
300 milliseconds
and another one 300 milliseconds after
that or 600 milliseconds from the
starting point
and what we get is this
[Music]
now this could work as the melody
but you're free to make it sound any way
you like
for example it could sound like this
[Music]
now to play it when finishing the puzzle
we just call this function here
[Music]
it sounds a bit bad because it overlaps
with the final popping noise when the
piece snaps into place
i fixed this by adding a small delay
here to the function call
[Music]
to store the scores we will need to use
some kind of database
i recommend going to the following link
and downloading xampp
it comes with mysql and phpmyadmin which
is a nice user interface for managing
database contents
xampp also includes the apache server
which we will need to write the backend
php code
after installing xampp we go to the
control panel and start these two
services
then we head on to the admin page
from here we can open phpmyadmin and
begin to construct our database to hold
the scores
we create a new database by pressing the
new button on the left and we give our
database a name
now we need to create a table
four columns are just fine
and let's call it scores
now every mysql table should have an id
field
we leave it as an integer type and mark
it as a primary key
and tick this checkbox right here so
that it will auto increment
this means that every time we'll add a
new score we don't have to worry about
its id anymore it will automatically be
decided by mysql
next we'll need to store the name of the
player here
it will be a string so we'll use varchar
as the data type and put a maximum
length of 255 characters here
might be a bit too much but never can
know what names people come up with
next we'll store the time
it can be an integer because i plan to
store the number of seconds
i can also add a comment here to clarify
the format so i don't need to remember
it later
and finally let's store the difficulty
level so that we can later group the
scores based on that now we press save
and we can see the table structure right
here
let's add some sample data to work with
it's going to be some fake placeholder
data for now
we go to insert and start entering
values in every field
but as i said earlier we don't need to
worry about the id
it will be automatically generated by
mysql
i'll just add my name here and let's say
it took me 50 seconds to complete the
puzzle on easy difficulty
then i'll add radu again and 100 seconds
while playing a medium
and again with 200 seconds on hard and
finally 4000 seconds on insane mode
so now it looks like i've played the
game on all difficulty levels
let's add a few more people here like
john with 20 seconds uneasy and 1000
seconds on insane
diana with 100 seconds on hard and 400
seconds also on hard
michael with 400 seconds on medium and
leo with 10 seconds on medium
now we press go and all these 10 entries
were added into the table
we can click on the browse tab to
inspect it
now we can actually see here the sql
query that outputs this entire table
it says
select everything from scores
we will later need to write similar
queries in php to communicate between
our frontend game and the database
this query right here could be useful to
load the scores for example but it's not
very nice as such
it mixes all difficulty levels and is
not sorted in any way
hard to see who the winners are like
this
so let's head on over to search and say
that we want only those entries with
easy difficulty
we can see how the sql query here is
updated as well
i think this phpmyadmin tool is very
useful for learning sql syntax
you can also practice writing the syntax
by yourself by pressing on edit
here we could for example add an order
by clause so that the results are sorted
by time
now it's really easy to see that john is
the winner when playing on easy mode
we can similarly obtain the results for
the other difficulty levels
we just need to change the difficulty
here each time
we'll use this query later in php to get
the high scores
now to add a new result we use the
insert keyword
we specify the table name and the
columns that will receive the data
and then the actual values that go into
it
note here that the name and difficulty
are strings so they need to be specified
using quotes otherwise you'll get an
error
then we press go
and get feedback that one row was
inserted
if we browse the table again we'll see a
new entry for radu on insane difficulty
now we'll practice these queries using
php and because this is the first time i
teach it i will take it slow
i've moved all project files of the game
built so far in the htdocs directory of
xaap
now i'll create an empty file called
server.php
we next open this file in our text
editor and in the browser
but note here the address is localhost
slash puzzlecam
server.php
you need to write it like that because
then the php code is executed by the
apache server
i remind you that you need to have xampp
installed and both apache and mysql
running at this stage
now php code is quite different from
javascript
the syntax starts and ends like this
and all the code goes in between
if you want to print something here you
use the keyword echo followed by what
you want to print
if you refresh the page you get exactly
that
now i'll teach you how to connect the
mysql database we created earlier
because it's also running locally on our
computer we'll use localhost as the host
the default user is root and the
password is empty
of course if you're gonna put this
online somewhere you'll want to add some
better security but i won't focus on
that in this video
then to connect to the database we use
the mysqli connect function and provided
this information
if the link was not established we
warned that the connection failed
the die function terminates the php
script as
well if the code passes the if statement
it will go here where we just echoed
that connection was successful
i'll refresh and connection was
successful
but if i specify a different host php
will produce some warning messages and
the program terminates after this die
statement
we also get an error message if we use
the wrong user or password
now with the successful connection we
can move on and select the database like
this
and we can use the or keyword to call
the die function in case of failure
if the code reaches here it will output
the success message
we can test and see that it was a
success because the puzzle cam database
really exists
if we mess up here and use a different
name for example the code will terminate
with an error
let's now define an sql query as a
simple string
i'll use the query we figured out
earlier using phpmyadmin
to select those entries from the scores
table with easy
difficulty we can execute this query
using the mysqli query function
now this function doesn't actually
return the result but an object that we
can use to iterate through the results
i'll show you
we first initialize an empty array
then if the result contains any rows we
will use a while loop to fetch each row
one by one using the mysqli fetch assoc
function on the rs object
we add each row to the results array
using the array push function and then
print the array using the print r
function like this
and we get an error
i forgot an i here it should be mysql i
num rows
now we have the array printed out here
but it's not sorted with respect to the
score or in this case playing time
as we saw earlier we can do that using
the order by clause
i'll also format this query a bit better
so it doesn't go outside the screen
note that in php the stop sign is used
for concatenation not the plus as in
javascript and many other programming
languages
now because we'll reuse this code to get
results for other difficulty levels it
makes sense to write this as a function
that returns the results array
we can then call it with easy as a
parameter and get the same result
let me just replace here the difficulty
to use this argument and
almost forgot need to specify the link
here as well
now we refresh and get the same result
as previously
but we can get other results as well by
calling the function again
let me quickly add the other difficulty
levels as well
now let's wrap all this into one
function to get all the scores
we don't need these print statements
anymore we can just return an
associative array with each of these
results
associative arrays are like javascript
objects where we can give names to the
keys
now we call this function and print the
result like this
or to be more familiar you can use echo
and convert this result array into a
json string like this
it's great that php has support for all
these without needing to install any
libraries
i'll comment this out and focus on
creating the other function we'll need
to add the new score to the database
i'll pass the information as the first
argument
for now i'll write the query as a simple
string with hard-coded values here
and then replace each value one by one
with the elements from the info
if you write your query like this it's
less likely to make mistakes
otherwise it's quite easy to mess up and
forget the single quote or a double
quote somewhere
now we call mysqli query again
if we don't succeed for some reason we
will return false
otherwise we return true to signify
success
now we can test the function like this
by defining some info and calling the
add score function using it
we can wrap it in an if statement like
this to see if the insert was a success
or not
and it claims to have worked let me now
bring back this function call to get all
the scores and see if it really worked
and it did
great
now we're gonna change this php server
to support both functionalities to add
the score and to read all the scores
let me remove this testing code first
now i'll use a get parameter named info
to send some additional information to
the page
let's first read it here and see how it
works
so i need to set here info equal to
something let's try hello for now
and you can see it is indeed printed
here
i'll change info now to contain
information necessary to add a score and
i'll write it as a json string
now to parse this string i call json
decode and get info as an object here
which i can pass to our add score
function we wrote previously and handle
the outcome as before
now we can insert the score by just
visiting this address with some
parameters
i'll now make it so that if we don't
send any info it will list all the
scores instead
in this way we support both reading and
writing to the database with this single
script
now let me address the elephant in the
room yes this code is not very secure
anyone can hack my scores database by
going to this link and sending some data
there
even worse this data is not escaped in
any way so they can even do some damage
through sql injections here
all these issues are not easy to fix and
if i spend time on it now it will
deviate too much from the project we are
building a puzzle game not making the
most secure thing in the world
but because many of you are interested
in security here's what you should do
first escape the information here or
even better use a prepared statement
change get here into post it's more
secure
i didn't do it myself because i would
need something like postman to test and
i didn't want to install more tools here
post is also the common practice when
sending data so you definitely should
use it here
then you'd want to add some
authentication here so that not everyone
can make a request such as this
you will need to ask people to register
and confirm their account by sending
them a confirmation email
i don't usually do this for my small
projects i feel i would be asking too
much from those visiting my website and
if i'm hacked so what i don't have any
sensitive information here and i kind of
like the attention
all these steps don't make the system
bulletproof but each of them make it a
little bit harder to hack
you could go even further like adding a
cap chat because
someone could automate the
authentication if they really want and
flood your database with a bunch of fake
accounts and fake scores
captchas make it harder to do but not
impossible
you could design some kind of validity
checking system here maybe record the
start time end time and individual moves
if the result doesn't contain pieces
moving one by one at reasonable time
intervals it's a sign of foul play
of course one could hack that too by
figuring out how the validity checker
works and generating fake data that
looks real
but
that's all i got so let me know if you
have better tips on security i'm really
interested to know what you guys think
but now let's continue with the front
end part let me put mr chibison here
again
in html i'll now create an end screen
it will show the score and allow the
user to enter his name in this input
field
there will also be a button to save the
score on click
we'll need to implement this save score
function in javascript
i'll also add here a button to show the
scores with another function we'll need
to define
and another button to go back to the
menu
i will also create the scores screen
it will contain an empty div which will
eventually hold the scores
and a button to go back to the end
screen we'll need to define this
javascript function as well now i'll
copy this title image in both these
screens so that they look consistent
and speaking about looks i'll define a
css class called menu and apply it to
all these items
this class will be the same style we
previously applied to the div with id
menu items
so we just change this here in css
now we refresh and we can see all three
screens overlapping each other
we need to hide the end screen and the
score screen in the beginning of course
now let's start defining the missing
functions in javascript first the one to
show the end screen
i will simply use the playing time as
the score and i'll place it inside the
element with id score value we also need
to compute this time as the end time
minus the start time we need to make
sure the end screen element becomes
visible too like this
then the function to show the menu will
begin by closing the end screen and then
making the menu appear
now if i refresh and press start the
menu disappears as before
but if i call the show and screen
function here in the console the end
screen appears and it looks good
but the score is now something strange
because we didn't actually complete the
puzzle to get the true value for the end
time
it will be okay when playing the game
for real we don't need to worry about
this
now pressing the menu
doesn't work
oh i forgot the parenthesis here we need
to call this function here on click
sorry about that
let's fix this and
refresh
start
call show and screen function in the
console
press menu
and yes it works now
let's move on to show the scores next i
will copy this line so that the end
screen goes away
and let's make the score screen appear
instead
now i'll make the score's container
initially showed the text loading
because it can take some time to load
the scores and we want to let the player
know something's happening
we then get the scores with the function
we'll implement next this getscores
function uses fetch to get data from
server.php
which i remind is located in the same
directory here
fetch returns a promise
when the response is available we
convert it into json
this returns another promise so we need
to write then again and here we have
access to the actual data
let's log it to the console to test
i refresh press start call show end
screen in the console and press show
scores and now our data is here
it still shows loading because now we
have to format the scores and place them
here instead
the format scores function will generate
a table in html
i won't explain this too much i feel
that this tutorial becomes too long if i
do that and if you were able to follow
up to here i'm sure you'll have no
trouble understanding what this is i
will say however that now when i have
the results formatted for easy i will
extract this functionality into its own
function it's a really bad habit to
write similar code instead of using
functions and many of my students have
this problem so i thought i pointed out
here as well
i now call this function for each
difficulty level to show all results one
after the other
the final list is just too long
i'll set the fixed height here and
overflow to auto so that the scroll bar
appears
this is better i think
now i press back and
i guess it's time to define the close
scores function
this is easy to do it will make the end
screen visible and hide the scores
screen
now i refresh and
everything seems to work well except for
this save feature that is not
implemented yet
the safescore function is going to
calculate the score as the time it took
to play the game
and get the player name from the input
field
if no name is entered we give a warning
and stop the function right here
otherwise we get the difficulty from the
select element and do a fetch to
server.php using the info parameter
where we pass the name playing time and
the difficulty level
to give feedback to the user i'll change
the text on the save button to say ok
during the fetch i disable this button
so that players can't press it multiple
times by mistake
i also reset the text on the save button
when opening the end screen again in
case the player plays a second time and
i need to re-enable the button as well
let's add the gray style for the
disabled button and make the cursor a
default arrow indicating that it can't
be clicked
now let's see
an error
of course
looks like i forgot the closing
parenthesis
before i test let's also call the show
end screen function here when the puzzle
is complete and test for real this time
okay works pretty well but
my score here is in milliseconds instead
of seconds
but on second thought i think it's
better to keep these in milliseconds so
that we can better distinguish between
people playing in almost the same time
i'll
format the score to show the number of
seconds but i keep milliseconds in the
database so that the ordering of the
ranked list comes from that
okay now the score appears to be the
number of seconds and the scores table
looks good too
those two have zero because we now
consider they played in 20 and 50
milliseconds but when we clear the
database and people actually start
playing this this problem will go away
one thing that still bothers me is that
the save button is on the next line but
then it becomes smaller when it says
okay and it jumps up i'll fix this by
making the input smaller so that the
button always fits on the same line
i'll also style it to be more consistent
with the other items
okay great
now we're going to do some fine tuning
and work on styling the pieces to look
like actual puzzle pieces
to do that we go to initialize pieces
function and iterate through the grid of
pieces like this
the pieces are stored in a list in this
top down and left to right order so we
can get the index of each piece by
simply counting here like this
now we take each piece one by one and i
and j will point to the row and column
where it belongs
we now need to add information about
these
things
to each piece
let's call them tabs
for each tab we need to know if it's an
inner tab or an outer tab
we'll decide that randomly with equal
probability like this
so this sign becomes either a minus one
or a plus one
telling if it's going to be an inner or
an outer tab
the second thing we need to decide is
where will the tab be located on the
edge
if we consider this to start at 0 and
end at 100 percent let's allow the tab
to be anywhere between thirty percent
and seventy percent
moving too close to the corners is not a
good idea
i'll now set this bottom attribute to
encode the information for the tab on
the bottom
it will be a single number between 0.3
and 0.7 if it's an outer tab and between
minus 0.7 and minus 0.3 if it's an inner
tab
note how we store both pieces of
information with this simple trick
if we are on the last row we don't have
any bottom tabs here so we'll set this
to null
we now do the same thing for the tab on
the right and make sure i don't add tabs
on the rightmost column
the top tabs are not going to be random
anymore because they need to connect
with the pieces from above
we need to set top to be minus the
bottom value of the piece directly on
top of it
if we're on the first row we don't have
a tab on the top
we now handle the left tab in a similar
way we use the value of minus the
previous piece's write attribute
now let's refresh make this console
bigger and check here what the pieces
array looks like
so the first piece has a positive value
here meaning it should be an outer tab
the right value is negative meaning it's
an inner tab
we have null for left and top so looking
good so far
for the second piece we need to check if
the left value is this number but
flipped
so let's
see yes
it looks good let's check again with the
next piece
good and now we get right equal to null
because we are on the rightmost column
now the next piece is on the next row so
the top is not null anymore and it
should be the opposite of the bottom of
the first piece
which it is
good let's see the last piece now too
it has no values for the bottom and
right and values for the left and top
look okay
yeah i think we're good
let's now draw new shapes for the pieces
using this extra information
we won't use direct method here anymore
but for now i'll just re-implement it
using move 2 and 4 line 2 commands
let me just add comments here to explain
where each of these lines is going
now refreshing doesn't change anything
pieces are still rectangle shaped but
now we have more control over this
drawing
i'm gonna need to know the minimum
length of the piece
and use it to define some visual
characteristics of the tab relative to
it
like the neck tab width and height
now let's first make a detour on our way
to top right like this
the location of the tab is given by the
absolute value of the top argument
we move on the vertical axis the tab
height in the direction given by the
sign of the top value
let's refresh now and see what happens
so pieces look a bit like houses with
some kind of roof
for some the roof goes inward like this
let me disable drawing of the video for
now it's confusing i think
so now you just see the shape of the
pieces but you can actually tell that
those with the flat roof belong on top
so we start to see that the shape of the
pieces really helps when playing the
game and makes the overall experience
nicer
let's continue i'll add similar detours
for the other sides as well
we refresh and
look at that
we get an interesting division now
i think this could actually be another
version of the game if so wanted
it's quite unique looking i think
an error where did that come from
ah i see
looks like it happens when i click
outside the piece
this here is considered to be outside
the piece because we're still using the
rectangle shape for hit detection but
the error appears every time i click out
here as well
can't believe i missed that
we need to make sure the selected piece
is not null before checking if it's
close or not
okay no more error
also notice how every time we refresh we
get different looking pieces this is
really nice i think
but now let's create the tabs
i'll make two more detours one before
this point and one after it and we use
the value of the neck we defined earlier
let me now quickly write this for the
other sides as well
i now refresh and
it looks okay but you see some of the
pieces have some weird lines sticking
out
not all pieces have it this one is okay
because it has tabs on all sides
the problem is that we add these new
detours even when an edge doesn't have a
tab
we need to check if we need to draw the
tab otherwise we just line two to the
end of the edge and that's it i'll
quickly add this to the other sides as
well and now
things look quite good
and notice that because we work with
values relative to the size of the
pieces it will work as expected on every
difficulty level when this size changes
no need to do anything special here at
all
now this shape is still not perfect we
need to add some curves
we'll replace this line here with the
bezier curve instead
i'll define it with the help of two
control points and this same endpoint
from earlier
looks like something's not right here i
think i'm missing this closing
parenthesis
but let me arrange this code better
anyway
refreshing and
now you can see what happened here
it makes a curve instead of a straight
line
i'll do the same thing on the right side
i just copy these lines in reverse order
and change this minus into a plus here
and here
we basically make it symmetrical
let's test and
it looks okay i think
if you want it to look differently you
can change these values here
like you can make the neck narrower
or you can make the tab wider for
example
you could actually even have different
properties for each piece if you want
it's not too much trouble but i think
it's overkill and i'm happy with this
being hard-coded here
notice that this also affected the other
tabs now
they are thinner and longer
i will make them all curved next by
adding similar code in each of these
sections
this is where i would usually say that
we should extract a function like draw
tab or something but i couldn't think of
good parameter names and it would
actually make some things more
complicated inside the function
so i decided to leave it like that but
the advice still stands just because i
can't figure out how to do it nicely
doesn't mean it can't be done
okay let's see
yeah
nice
and again it works on any size pieces
now all we need to do is add the video
back in
i'll move the code right
here and before it i call the clip
method of the context and i save the
state before the clip and restore it
after the call to draw image so it won't
affect the following pieces in a weird
way
now some of the pieces look great like
this one
but those that have an outer tab are
missing the video inside it
we fix this by taking the video with
some padding on each side
a padding equal to the tab height is
enough
because the size of the puzzle and the
size of the video don't match we need to
scale this tab height for the first four
parameters like this
note that i actually divide here by this
size so essentially i'm simplifying here
it would have been better to store the
percent values only but i noticed this
just when editing the video so now it's
too late
anyway this works
or not
looks like i have an extra parenthesis
here
it's supposed to close after the min
method here
now it works and it looks great
only thing remaining is to handle when
user clicks inside the tabs
the outer tabs are not clickable and the
inner tabs select the piece even when it
shouldn't
you would think that it's not a big
issue but if pieces overlap like this
you won't get the piece below it and
it's very annoying
you don't want to annoy your players now
do you
to fix this we will re-implement the way
we select the pieces i will use a
different strategy for this
bear with me for a while as i implement
some things that may seem unrelated
first let's make a function to generate
a random caller it will first generate a
random red component between 0 and 255
and we make it into an integer using
floor
we do the same for the green and blue
values and return it as a string using
the rgb syntax like this
now we'll generate a random color for
each piece
we really want the colors to be unique
and it's very unlikely for duplicates to
happen especially when the game has only
a few pieces
but on insane mode
i don't know
better safe than sorry and check if a
collar was used before and regenerated
in that case
we'll pass this caller to each piece and
now in the piece class we store it as an
attribute
then in the draw method we'll specify a
second argument that tells whether to
use the camera or not
default set to true
if true the code here stays the same but
if not it will draw the pieces using
their color instead like this
i use the fill rect method here and add
a padding of tab height so that the
outer tabs are colored as well
now let's test by setting use cam to
false
everything still works but now the
pieces are more colorful and the camera
input is not used anymore
you can actually play the game like this
based on the shape alone it's quite easy
on easy mode at least
now we did this change because i want to
use the clicked caller to detect if i'm
clicking on a piece or not
like here it should not detect a click
because there's nothing there and here
it should activate because i'm pressing
on a pink color
the piece with the color i'm clicking on
should start dragging
we implement this by going to the
unmousedown callback function and
getting the color information from where
we clicked on the canvas
we get the image data at event.x and
event.y as an array with four elements
first is for red second is for green
third is blue and fourth is the
transparency i check if the fourth
element is zero so
transparent and return in this case
we're not clicking on anything then
this is not white actually it's
transparent black
but if we pass this part we format the
color in the rgb string format and check
to see where it belongs inside the piece
we need to implement a new function for
that but it's really easy
i'll use this other function as a
reference and pass the color here as a
second argument
now we loop through these pieces as
before and if the color matches we
return that piece
simple as that
now if you want to make the code more
efficient you could store the pieces in
a dictionary with keys equal to the
color values and then do this lookup in
constant time instead of linear but this
method here works just fine we don't
have that many pieces even on insane
mode
okay let's refresh and test
it works but now you're going to say but
rado so what if it works we want to see
the webcam image here not some random
colors
and to that i say multiple canvases
we'll add another canvas here i'll call
it helper canvas
and now in javascript i'll refer to it
as well in the same way we did for the
other
one we then set its width and height to
be the same as well
now in update game i'll also clear the
helper canvas like this
and then draw the pieces normally with
camera data on the main canvas but using
the colors on the helper canvas
and the trick is that now on mouse down
we don't take the color data from the
main canvas we take it from the helper
canvas instead let me just refresh and
you'll get it in a sec
or a couple of seconds
it doesn't work
i forgot to change the id here to help
her canvas
okay
now my elements show the helper canvas
somewhere here below
let me just move it into screen like
this
i'll make it smaller so it doesn't
overlap as much and i'll put it in the
corner here
now when i click somewhere on the main
canvas the corresponding color value
comes from this helper canvas
so selecting the piece now works as
expected
and both canvases update at the same
time making the helper canvas a reliable
hit detector for our pieces
this helper canvas doesn't need to be
visible
actually it doesn't even need to be
added to the dom but it can be there as
well it's useful for debugging i think
i'll just set the display here in line
to none and that's it
let's test one final time
[Music]
that's it hope it was worth it and that
you learned something from this
and if you did please like and share
this video with anyone you think is
interested
you can download the source code from my
website
it's split into parts so you can take it
step by step if you want
also let me know if you can think of a
good strategy to play the game
it took me one and a half hours to solve
the insane mode with 1000 pieces
there must be a smarter way of doing
this
anyway thanks for watching and see you
guys